IRIS UY: Hi, I'm Iris.
EMMA YEAP: And I'm Emma.
IRIS UY: And we're engineering
practicum interns this summer
at Google Sydney.
EMMA YEAP: Today,
we're going to talk
about what we've been
working on over the summer.
We've added heat maps to the
Google Maps Android API utility
library.
IRIS UY: On a map,
we use a heat map
to visualize the large number
of geographical points.
Different colors or
opacities represent areas
with different
intensities of points.
In general, higher
intensities correspond
to warmer colors,
hence the name.
EMMA YEAP: Heat maps, which
are also sometimes called
intensity maps, are
useful for visualizing
large geographical data sets
to display overall location
trends.
IRIS UY: For
example, here we use
heat maps to illustrate the
different types of places
around Sydney's CBD.
A place is a point of
interest that has a location.
For example, a restaurant
or shop or attraction.
EMMA YEAP: This demo uses the
radar search from the Google
Places API to obtain
search results
for a user-inputted
keyword and renders
the location of the
results as a heat map.
If the user enters
more key words,
the app creates more heat map
layers with different colors,
allowing the user to
visually compare the results.
IRIS UY: Find out more
about the Places API
from the developer
documentation.
The heat maps
library is included
as part of the Google Maps
Android API utility library.
Instructions on how
to set up the library
and where you can view the
source code are linked below.
EMMA YEAP: We've
used a tile overlay
to display the heat map.
A tile overlay is
a set of images
displayed over the map tiles.
To do this, we first
create a tile provider,
which creates tile
images client side.
Then we create a tile overlay
with the tile provider
and add it to the map.
IRIS UY: To start off with,
create a new heat map tile
provider using the builder.
You must provide a
collection of lat longs
or weighted lat longs that
represent your input data.
EMMA YEAP: A weighted lat
long can be created from a lat
long and, optionally,
has an intensity value
that you can use
to weight points.
Other openings are also
configurable at this stage,
such as which colors
the heat map uses.
IRIS UY: The colors are defined
using the gradient class.
The gradient is created
using two arrays.
An integer array
representing the colors,
and a float array
representing the values
that the respective
colors represent.
These floats are
expressed as fractions
from zero to one of
the maximum intensity
value of the heat map.
EMMA YEAP: For example,
the default heat map
is generated with
the values shown.
The gradient class uses these
and interpolates between them
to generate the colors
used in the heat map.
You can create the heat map
with your own custom gradient
by providing it to
the builder as shown.
IRIS UY: Now, use this provider
to add a new tile overlay
to your map.
This is all you need to add
a basic heat map to a map.
EMMA YEAP: You can change
options such as radius,
opacity, and gradient both
at and after creation.
You can also change the data set
to completely different data,
or to an updated version.
IRIS UY: To do this,
call the relevant set x
method on the provider, then
clear the overlay's tile case
so that it redraws all the tiles
with the new option values.
EMMA YEAP: Thank
you for watching.
IRIS UY: Also, if you'd like
to learn more about student
opportunities and intern
programs at Google,
visit the link below.